i was the one to dive on it
dove on it identified her vehicle and uh
yeah we we found her her unborn baby and
courtney in the vehicle was still there
nothing but an accident
[Music]
howard doss we're back for another
episode of cocktails and cocktails how
you been buddy good man how you doing
i'm doing well um so
this week we have we're kind of
venturing outside directly
talking to a cop or somebody like that
which we do quite frequently here on the
show we try to get anybody and everybody
that's some way out there
impacting touching um you know helping
victims of crime criminal justice system
and so forth
and we have got uh one guy here from a
duo
i got interrupts though yes sir
don't you have some news don't you have
a show that returned to the air that
maybe
somebody might be interested in we do we
do uh it was kind of a big deal i mean
if you call the number one cable show on
television every friday and saturday
night a big deal you mean the dating
game well you know what i'll say this
the the the gentlemen we have on here
from their organization i think they
have like over two million subscribers
uh to their youtube channel so they're
obviously doing quite well there we had
two 2.1 million viewers
uh an episode with you know friday and
saturdays at times so
we've got that uh that thing in common
with one another but yeah so uh big news
you know i've put it out on social media
it's been picked up throughout the media
um you know our show that went off the
air in may of 2020
uh is basically coming back
and uh as of right now as of the time of
this recording of this episode the
working title name is on patrol live
nice so
nice thank you thank you yeah long
overdue long overdue very very happy so
um yeah we'll see um you know it's going
to be live every friday and saturday
night we start july 22nd so
uh going to be on the rios cable channel
and
you can if you've got direct directv
dish network uh a lot of other things
out there you can find it so well i'm
just going to tell you it's about
goddamn time damn right it's been too
long damn right all right so go ahead
let's talk about our gas all right so
the gentleman we have on here with us
today for those of us or those that are
watching it on youtube or watching it
here on the tv they get to see this
gnarly looking beard i'm sure he's heard
it a million times it's there's nothing
like having a good look that makes you
stand out um he probably hears
comparisons to duck dynasty and so forth
i imagine through the years
but we have got uh doug bishop with us
from adventures with purpose um he's one
half of the duo where he also partners
up with jared is it lysic or lasik how's
his name pronounced
it is jared leisak jerry lysak so the
two of these guys uh they've got a group
called adventures with purpose they are
out there doing amazing things over just
roughly two plus years now from my
understanding but we're going to jump in
and let him talk about their
organization and some of the
stories where they have helped uh you
know they've helped law enforcement
agencies find missing people but more
importantly they have helped bring
closure to families
um that have been through some tough
times so uh jared i'm sorry uh doug
thank you so much for being with us here
now as we always talk about here on
cocktails and cocktails uh you're going
to provide the tails for us we're going
to have cocktails
and today
what are we drinking oh we're drinking
some fine elixir one of our uh one of
our good friends has a um has company
and uh he has uh partnered with lots of
people one of the things he's partnered
with is a local brewer he's making some
of this
fine bolt monkey deckhand lager so we're
gonna have some of that today
so we don't usually drink beer we don't
usually drink beer hey doug what are you
drinking
uh i have silver star whiskey from
silver star spirits down at texas
won a few awards for their uh honey
whiskey
huh nice we like honey we'll cheers to
you sir thanks for being on cheers
cheers absolutely
all right doug i know you've kind of had
to run through this because you guys uh
you know like i mentioned have over two
million youtube subscribers right now
and uh so you guys have kind of exploded
over the last few years which i'm sure
has been
an eye-opener for you but all for good
reasons
how did uh how'd you get involved with
this and how did you end up partnering
up with jared
sure yeah i just want to start off by
saying thank thanks for having us on
here to spread awareness to our purpose
and a long time a fan a supporter of
yours and everything you've done
throughout law enforcement and also post
law enforcement with the show as well
much love that
big news on the show coming back like
wow like
it's it's two million i think you can
see he's smiling two million viewers per
episode i believe it was yeah that's
where i think you know we were hitting
that on some friday and saturday nights
it did very very well so uh man like i
said
not to cut you off long overdue really
looking forward to getting back in
studio you know tom morris is not going
to be brought the show but we've got a
guy by the name of curtis wilson
um who anybody who's a viewer you know
from richmond county sheriff's
department that they've been on it since
episode one up until the end and he's
from there so of course dan abrams is
the host man so yeah we're excited
killer team and uh you know the time off
honestly he's done nothing but build
demand so those two million i would say
are gonna be you're going to have an
easy 3 million average per episode i
firmly believe i promise reals would
love that
[Laughter]
for reels
getting into us you know we're
adventures with purpose we are an
underwater sonar search and recovery
dive team
we travel the nation assisting families
and law enforcement and we're able to do
so free of charge to both families and
law enforcement as well
and it's the community that puts us in
the position
to be able to do what we do
um
how long has uh adventures with purpose
basically been in operation
um you know from what i've read you you
were
hell this wasn't your background you
weren't a diver i mean this wasn't what
you you you did basically um how did you
and doug end up i'm sorry you and jared
end up hooking up and making this thing
happen
yeah so um roughly about two and a half
years ago i was operating a towing
company here in portland oregon elite
towing and recovery i received an email
from a diver who reached out to me
uh stated his purpose was cleaning up
water environments by taking trash out
um he
explained you know how he had a youtube
channel with a few thousand subscribers
and that he ran across a car here
underwater in portland and would i help
him nobody else would help him and
wanted it you know basically said you
know he wasn't able to pay me to pull it
out but if i was able to donate our
services come together we could pull it
out for a great cause and
after getting the email
absolutely you know i responded back and
said you know i want us to be a part of
this uh me and my daughters you know
we're big outdoors here all summer long
swimming in the rivers lakes anybody who
knows pacific northwest
we protect our waters we're real green
up here um as we should be and you know
we jared jared and i you know
teamed up clicked
we pulled that first car out
and that one car that he found quickly
turned into over 25 cars that first
summer
here just in the city of portland alone
doug were these cars i mean were they
just in you know rivers ponds waterways
you name it you know just wherever he
basically came across them and was it
him finding all these and then you came
out and you know did your yeah
yeah yeah he was spending his time
underwater uh you know removing trash
and stuff from the waterways his purpose
was environmental and once he found that
first car and we teamed up to pull that
first car out
you know he just kept running into cars
underwater here and i kept coming out we
kept filming all of these recoveries
and the viewers you know when it where
it started out with several thousand
followers on youtube we start pulling
these cars out together
it just started to blow up you know
people like seeing these cars coming out
the waterways being cleaned up
and uh
shortly thereafter i believe we were
probably at about right around our 20th
car pulling out
we've pulled out a car unexpectedly with
human remains in it
oh shit
yeah then that's and that's that's what
we were actually on a live stream and
that that's sort of where that is where
everything changed for us
um and not to mention in finding these
cars
we're using sonar we're not just jared
wasn't just diving on cars we're using
sonar topside you know cutting edge you
know fish finders
which the public knows them as
and we're not realizing that we're
organically teaching ourselves how to
read sonar
that is extremely rare um
and viewers start reaching out to us we
see what you're capable of we see you
finding these cars
we have a loved one that is missing
can you come help us
um we know we made that first trip out
to you know help her find her son her
son was exactly where she thought he was
and that's when we really knew that you
know
our
skills that we built
unexpectedly had a bigger purpose
and now we specifically target cases
cold cases where people are missing and
missing with a vehicle
mowing the lawn yes mowing the lawn
whether it be the yard out in front or
behind the house or the one
below on the body right or on the back
side of the body right or any of those
places but if you're gonna mow the lawn
what do you need you need a lawnmower
the new lawnmower 4.0 4.0 it's a big one
they sent us some of these we tried it
out not on each other we've we've done
it on the own privacy of our home we did
try it out on each other but we're not
going to tell everybody that the uh and
man these are awesome no they actually
they are fantastic listen i have uh
my entire adult life um i have been a
fan of
body maintenance i guess would be the
term to use
body hair maintenance hygiene exactly
it's for a hygiene thing um and i have
gone through different things through
the years and this manscape 4.0 the
lawnmower 4.0 i'm sorry that was sent
out to us uh it's a great little box
game with all kinds of stuff man you got
that you got the 4.0 in there you got a
little nose trimmer
you got a pair of underwear yeah and
you've got that ball deodorant
excuse me you have that
no no square deodorant yes the no no
yeah so it's it's a hell of a kit that
they send out and listen for all the
listeners out there whether you are a
man yourself and you're looking for
something to keep the body looking
trimmed up uh you yourself have a father
the the young uh you know the wives that
are out there and so forth
get on manscape.com get yourself that
kit get it sent out to the house then
you can use code sticks
on there as well s-t-i-c-k-s
manscape.com yes
so when that first one you pulled out
you found human remains in
um
obviously that was a shock
what whose remains were those who'd you
contact who came out and looked at it
how did you identify this i mean the
license plate does a lot i know yeah
right yeah yeah yeah so so we we were
pulling the car up
um jared found this car in an 80-foot
hole
uh in the willamette river uh just south
of portland oregon and we just like it
was any other car um i'm there on deck i
have my driver there with the rollback
he's pulling it up and as soon as the
car breaks the waterway onto the boat
ramp jared's next to the driver's side
door and he's like whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa call the cops call cause he's
identifying human remains and the
drivers still in the driver's seat seat
belted in
and uh it was just like
zero to 100 in a split second
so how do this guy just was he in an
accident did he drive off the boat ramp
was he
um you know we don't know
we don't know for sure but we suspect it
was suicide his name was timothy
robinson and he had been missing for 12
years you know his family
stated to us that they simply thought
that
he vanished and went overseas somewhere
just they never knew
you know that's gonna be terrifying for
like a family member like if today but
heaven forbid one of my children just
disappeared the hole that would be left
to me would be
oh absolutely you know and
and i think that's a big part of this
you know what they're doing is
i don't want to necessarily say foul
play but a lot of the missing person um
cases i'm assuming you guys get involved
involved with
a lot of them are just going to be some
of those cars that went off the roadway
um you know ice a bridge you know they
they were driving from this location to
list this location and we never heard
from him again
um and so you're absolutely right it's
just that complete unknown
and that's the hard part about it it's
like man you know my kid my mom whoever
was they left the house and they're
heading over to such and such his house
and never to be seen again their cars
never found you know because from you
know the uh
i guess ones that you know missing
person cases that have
uh
you know unusual circumstances or you
know we think there's some sort of a
crime you you're going to find a car
you're going to find something that goes
man something happened here
um yeah when just they completely
vanished like that and that's why i
think it is just just amazing that you
guys are able to get out there and do it
and it's beside the the sonar um i
definitely want to talk about how you
guys use that but i assume for some of
the cases uh especially some of the the
modern day ones
um
you know some of the other factors we'll
use that example someone's left you know
my house heading over to howards this is
the typical route they would take
there's a body of water or a river
they went missing and you guys are using
things like cell phones and stuff like
that as well is that correct
that that is that is correct you know
we'll we'll come into this these cases
like any investigator would you know
we're looking for
we're trying to determine lost person
behavior that gives us a good idea of
where we should look are there is there
a last known location is there any
evidence like a cell phone
video surveillance
and you know when somebody's missing and
missing with a vehicle you know
i know missing persons cases in a hole
is just a really tough thing for law
enforcement in general
the overwhelming majority of people who
go missing always turn back up yeah um
really there's
and there's there's a there's a
justification of use of resources
agencies have to use and
unfortunately you know
you law enforcement has to be put in a
position where they say either a this is
something's bad happened here or b
uh you know this is uncharacteristic we
need to put all of our efforts into it
right away and you know
that's that's where we kind of come in
after things have died and gone cold and
we're able to put together you know a
new set of eyes to the case and also
expertise in a real weird gray area that
involves law enforcement which is sonar
um you know a majority of the people
that we find are in areas where multiple
agencies have already
searched
but because there isn't a necessary like
a flat out school a training school for
sonar
it's really easy to think you know how
to read sonar and
unfortunately you don't
and you know and that's not to knock law
enforcement at all whatsoever it's just
something that and honestly there's
no reason for us to know what we know
and it's just really organic the way
that we've learned it
you know and doug i'm gonna hit one of
the deals i've kind of written down a
few of the incidents i know you guys
have come out and
again you know found uh vehicles found
people and and one of them here that
kind of just stood out you just
basically exactly what you were talking
about was a uh a man by the name of
antonio lopez
um you know that was missing out there i
think it was february of last year
february 2021
um
yeah and multiple law enforcement
agencies i think the coast guard
uh different groups came out searching
an area body of water
over 10 days and unfortunately we're not
successful in finding them and then you
guys did come out and if the information
i read was correct again just because
you guys as you said almost dumb luck
you've learned how to use this sonar as
well as you have and it was something
like within 10 or 15 minutes you guys
actually found the car
yeah yeah you're you're absolutely
correct and
uh yeah that was a tough one you know um
we're we're never
there to show boat we're never there to
cowboy anything we're just there to help
we really we really understand that the
the skills that we've developed
are something rare and we just want to
use them as much as we can
and you know thankfully now today with
the success that we've had you know law
enforcement is just
their open arms you want to come help
help us you know we've got requests all
over the nation for different cases and
also to train
uh but that particular case was uh
pretty tough you know um
he was only in 12 feet of water and even
when we located him
the agencies that were there still
couldn't locate him after we've
basically told them where they were but
if you're going too fast if you're going
with the current instead of against the
current you know what you what is a car
is going to look like a pebble you know
so there's just it's
it's not a knock on them i'm just glad
that we were there that day to to help
find him and uh bring him home to the to
his family
well i've got a couple of questions
first off let's say that
let's use tulsi you know a lot about
tulsa i do uh when they have like a
rescue recovery department i assume
right yep yeah we've got a dive team you
know from the police department and
the fire department does as well right
well they're too busy uh doing calendar
shoots so they can lifting weights and
grocery shopping and
they grocery shopping the biggest car
ever i've said it before on here the bet
the best i tell you i know i've said it
on a previous episode i'm going to say
it again i love the firemen and
there is obviously this joking thing
that goes back and forth absolutely love
them to death i'll never forget the time
i was running hot to a call and i passed
the fire station
and they were out in the front yard
throwing fucking frisbees i swear i
swear i swear man i'm going lights and
siren pass it and they are throwing
frisbees you know why they're throwing
frisbee it really works your forearms
yeah yeah
no hey hey good good for those guys man
okay so you've got you've got these guys
going out there your dive team goes out
they think of cars they actually see
like the signs like skid marks going off
and they can find it that's pretty easy
right but i mean we're talking around
tulsa man some murky water oh yeah i
mean
we've got some uh the reservoir out in
east tulsa i mean i know there's people
or vehicles gone missing in there before
and then obviously we've got
arkansas river right you know somebody
goes off down into into that luckily
hell in tulsa arkansas river half the
time i was getting water right
there it is you could walk across it
like for real
this has happened yeah but no you know
just as he's saying i mean it is a uh
they've developed an expertise
and
you know that i think the justice
department says that there's roughly
like 600 000 people that are reported
missing a year in the us right so that
is a tremendous number i mean there's
roughly six seven hundred thousand
police officers total in the country so
yeah when you when you look at it like
that um
but just as he pointed out the vast
majority of them there's not you know
suspicious circumstances it's somebody a
kid who has a fight with his parents and
just leaves and comes back two days
later i mean there's a whole lot of that
stuff you know husband and wife that are
having problems one of them leaves for a
few days but they get reported missing
they do come back
we in law enforcement
don't have the resources for all the
things that are going on as it is and
especially you know some of these
missing person cases that are not
criminal in nature not to say nobody's
you know looking into it not to say we
don't care um obviously we do and you
know and just as as doug pointed out the
ones that happen right away where it's
you know a little kid missing or what we
call a silver alert an older person
who's you know got dementia or something
is you know driving this car man we we
everyone's gonna you know all the free
officers at that time we're gonna get
out there and try to look for him but
some of these other cases that these
guys are able to work on and
you know find and recover
the police department again it's not
that they don't care they just don't
have the time or the resources to put in
what these guys are able to do
absolutely so you guys feel a great
niche there
yeah yeah
fortunately you know it's uh we're
taking it very serious and
uh you know we actively in our database
that we've been able to form we have
over 2500 cases where people are missing
and missing with cars and that's what we
that's what we estimate to be less than
ten percent of what's really out there
with people involving cars
well i read somewhere that you guys have
a um about a 16 to 18 solve
yeah
now we're up to 19.
nice one out of five one out of five
which is involving cold cases absolutely
unheard of unheard of um
and
yeah we're just trying to stick with it
man we really are we it's there's
there's nothing
i couldn't imagine doing anything else
other than giving families the answers
that we give them you know when when
you're able to do that
there's just nothing more powerful that
type of purpose is
you know i would have jared and i both
say to each other all the time like
would
we joke between each other do you think
three years ago when we met we would be
where we're at today absolutely not
isn't life funny
it is it is you know when you take that
chance you take that risk um
you just never know and
i i knew
in hindsight i knew when i very first
met jared that our friendship was
special
and what we were gonna do together was
special i didn't know it at the time but
looking back i knew it you know and we
you know he's a great guy and uh you
know just very glad we we started what
we started together and started pulling
them cars out
i've been in the towing industry since i
was in high school
so for me to
leave the towing industry
um
that was scary it was it was scary i
mean it's similar to you you were a cop
you took that leap
and that leap changed your life
yeah
it did
and you know me getting out of towing
and using my rigging and towing
experience and
you know common sense investigative
skills in working cold cases
one of the best things i've ever done
you know and you you answer the question
for me i was going to ask are you still
you know towing is this just something
you do on the side type of deal and it
sounds like when this is kind of and you
guys are a volunteer organization you're
not charging families when you go out is
that correct yep that is correct we
never charge a family a dime we never
ask anybody for anything law enforcement
or families
we don't even ask for rewards when
there's rewards in a case
if one is gifted to us we will honor it
but we don't we don't pursue it
yeah i mean and the donations that come
in or through the sales of something off
your website or what your youtube
generates i mean that's what's using to
fund
what you guys are doing to go out and do
more of these that's correct
that that is absolutely correct we're
community driven all the way around uh
through donations uh youtube
monetization facebook monetization you
know so something as simple as somebody
subscribing liking sharing following
leaving a comment that's all a
contribution um you know we have hats
and you know shirts and so forth you
know buying a t-shirt helps fund
everything that we do you thought about
doing an only fan just featuring your
beard yeah you could you could have like
[Music]
baby birds come out of it like at the
bottom people like or rabbits like a
rabbit would be nice right out of the
bottom cute one i've been asked that so
many times it's so much so that i mean i
might as well right hey do it hey we'll
we'll we'll pay we'll sign up why not
yeah yeah
might as well okay so let's talk about
that beard for a second so you went from
toe to diving right and you dive correct
yes yes correct
i assume you got paddy certified i got
paddy certified isn't that what it's
called
yeah yeah yeah so um shortly after you
know getting into this real hard with
jared i was like man
um
a little background like you know
growing up i used to read national
geographic all the time and i used to
see these beautiful pictures of blue
oceans and so as a small child i always
wanted to be an oceanographer i wanted
to be that one underwater in beautiful
water so there was there was a kind of a
part of me that always wanted to be
underwater um i i never got into that
but
in getting into this with jared and
helping families i i was like i'm
getting certified i got to be the one
underwater rigging my cars doing all
that good stuff putting my
my lifelong skill set to work underwater
and you know
here it is i'm a diver i'm underwater
i'm filming but it's chocolate milk you
know but it's
i couldn't imagine getting underwater
for a better purpose though you know
absolutely
so you're wearing a wetsuit you know
getting into wetsuits pretty tough just
getting the body in there and i i'm
going off the beard you're right you're
probably pretty hairy dude so that
neoprene grabs a little bit i know i
know what's going on i'm a little hairy
in spots myself yeah so
so we actually use dry suits we usually
how do you get that beard in there
um so i'll use the dry suit because
obviously we have to stay dry we're in
freezing cold temperature waters when
we're searching some of these lakes and
you know in north america like
20 degree water you know you'd say water
that's below freezing yeah water that's
like when i get out everything's frozen
instantly in the air
but i use a neoprene hood that covers my
whole head
and leaves like a sealed skin
around here
so my beard is rolled up inside of my
hood and then i use a full face mask
which suctions to the seal skin around
it so my beard has never seen at all
it's completely tucked away inside of my
uh full head hood
because if you were going to have to
condition that after diving that would
take a little while right get it all
cleaned up get the brine
yeah all right let's talk
let's let's talk about uh uh some of the
work you did in arkansas that's pretty
close to where we are right you went
down there i
i know that you helped a a a young lady
find her mom and her sister
yes
that is correct russellville arkansas
so you want to tell us the details of
that case
yeah yeah sure
um so we uh initially were tipped off by
fans supporters in the area
about a case with a young lady who had
been missing with her daughter for the
last 22 years
we came out we searched we were
unsuccessful
a lot of times you know we do our best
to try to reach out to law enforcement
and family
but it's not always that we can arrange
that in time so we ended up filming this
episode
without the family i believe the
information we had was old information
so it wasn't getting through to the
family
um
we put the episode out the family sees
it and it's like oh my god like
we want you to come back you know we
would love to be there if you guys could
just come back and do another search and
so forth uh there's some other areas and
some information we'd like to share with
you that could possibly help you out and
you know make you more efficient on
another search and by all means
absolutely we're coming back
so we came back to town um daughter flew
up from florida because that's where she
now resides
um mom is still there in town
um basically
uh samantha her name is samantha hopper
um she was
eight months pregnant i believe eight or
eight months pregnant she when she went
missing she has two daughters ages two
courtney holt
and um desiree were her two daughters
now she lived with her mom
and she's also eight months pregnant
like i said um she's got a best friend
and her
baby daddy is lives up in tennessee
so she wants to go see baby daddy she
wants to get away and she tells her mom
she's got to go to a concert it's like
i'm going to a concert can you watch the
children for me well mom and dad have a
lot going on i believe dad was in and
out of the hospital there was just with
a spur the moment i need to leave you
need to watch the kids mom was like you
know i really can't do that however i
will watch one for you
so
she left desiree
with her mom
took her two-year-old she took her
two-year-old courtney to
her baby daddy's house in town
and this is again unexpected so baby
daddy was like man it's my anniversary
i'm leaving out the door right now give
me two hours come back and i'll watch
her for you
and that was the last she was seeing
so
um
that we come to town we have the family
there they reiterated everything that i
just told you so we try to put ourselves
in her shoes like
she wants to go to her baby daddy's
house because we met with the best
friend and the best friend was like yeah
she wasn't going to a concert she was
going up there so we were like all right
what what would samantha do in the event
she has courtney but her mom confirmed
she didn't have a diaper bag didn't have
any extra clothes so what is she going
to do at that point getting refused
by baby daddy and we were we speculated
okay she's going to go back to mom's
house one more time to at least get a
bag of clothes
or beg mom please just go ahead and
watch courtney too you know you're
already watching desiree just please do
this for me regardless we theorized she
was gonna go back home so we took the
route that she would have taken from
baby daddy's house back home and then
looked at
bodies of water that were close to the
road along that route and you know less
than less than an hour on our search we
discovered a vehicle that was
right off of a little roadway overpass
it's not even a bridge it's just where a
little
uh corner of the lake
curves under the road and there's a
little park there
uh we discovered a vehicle right under
the other side of that bridge
uh we were looking for a ford taurus an
old-school ford uh for tempo
and i i was i was the one to dive on it
dove on it identified her vehicle
and uh yeah we we found her her unborn
baby and courtney in the vehicle was
still there
nothing but an accident you know she her
friend acknowledged us that you know she
was an aggressive driver she did drive
pretty aggressive and
just in an area where you know it was an
accident was it an accident that was her
fault did she run into somebody and
somebody never say anything could have
been
um there were never really big railings
on that bridge so it was really easy to
go off of and just real tragic accident
you know after 23 years
at that point you know she had been
missing you know we were able to give
her entire family answers that day
uh definitely one of the toughest cases
i've worked anytime you can
find three people you know it's just a
blessing for them
yeah i can only imagine you know for for
you guys that are out there as well as
for the family
um and so that one's 23 years i know
there's another one that's even longer i
think there's like someone who's missing
for 30 and we'll get into that but the
question i actually have so you guys are
out of oregon you travel to arkansas on
this particular case we're talking about
i know you guys done it across the
country when you guys travel to these
places
are you bringing like your own towing
equipment or you guys hooking up with
locals there to go hey man we found this
vehicle and then you guys get a tow
company out there but because of your
expertise you're the guy that then goes
back down in the water hooks it and so
forth
yeah so
when we find something that we're
looking for
um at that moment it's a crime scene
we're calling in authorities and you
know together you know the authorities
they they will you know they'll ask us
what kind of resources we need to get
the car out and it just becomes a big
cooperative you know effort there with
uh law enforcement wherever we're at at
that time
well i've got some not that i'm trying
to get into your business or anything i
definitely don't i don't like murky
water i don't even like swimming pools
at night with the lights off okay so
don't don't take it that way um
do you float these up these cars up off
the bottom you use float bags is that
what i was seeing
in certain instances we do use lift bags
um but nowadays you know where it's it's
it's
rare that we use lift bags
we're bringing in you know great big
rotators you know million dollar tow
trucks cranes
and so we're able to really rely on the
um you know the big large equipment to
do it real efficiently um but but we do
use lift bags from here and they're just
different scenarios depends on where the
car is at the conditions and so forth
do you um
what is it like when you go down you you
find a vehicle
you look inside in this murky water can
you visualize a body in there
um
no
very very rare um
you know most of the time i can barely
see
my hand in front of my face
um i i fight to even read my gauges or
my dive system
so it's it's murky it's it's chocolate
milk and honestly most of time my eyes
are closed because
when we find a car on sonar we drop a
magnet on it and then a line topside to
a buoy that way when i'm when i'm diving
i'm not just searching i know i'm diving
on a target straight down the line
to the car
i'm i'm orienting myself on the car all
right i got my mirror i know i'm on the
driver's side or tail light headlight um
i have my lights a lot of times i can
you know getting right up close i'm able
to you know see emblems and license
plates and stuff but it's uh
it's really easier for me to do a lot of
times with my eyes closed because i'm
just my hands are more use it feels like
they're more useful to me with my eyes
closed my eyes looking at chocolate
cloudy milk isn't helping me you know
that's nuts honestly i would have never
even thought about that the magnets are
yeah i mean it sounds so simple but it's
something i would've never even thought
of cars yeah we we we use great big
uh 2600 pound magnets the great big
fishing magnets that everybody uses uh
we actually have them on our website to
offer to people who can
try to do what we're doing
and that's another thing in our episodes
um
we're not we're not chefs that have a
secret recipe and aren't telling anybody
we're open books if you're a fisherman
or if you're a guy that has a
the ability to explore rivers and so
forth we're always encouraging people to
do what we're doing we're showing the
tools that we're using to do it and you
know the the at the end of the day the
more people that can do what we're doing
the better we're not
we're not trying to keep the secrets to
ourselves and so forth and uh so you
know as us using our tools and we're
just open books when we're working the
case the cameras are on and what happens
happens it's it's nothing's enhanced or
fake um you
you get whatever happens that day
uh
doug so you guys did the you're talking
about going back when you guys first
hooked up just kind of talking about the
camera's rolling you said you guys were
live streaming when that first uh you
know human remains were found in a car
do you guys still live stream at all now
or is everything pretty much just
recorded and then you know uploading
youtube
it is
we do not live stream when we're working
a case anymore at all okay uh yeah
do due to
how things have progressed so much we
can't we can't risk that um you know a
lot of times we have
agencies that are with us that don't
even want to be seen
undercover officers that don't want to
be seen and
just to protect the integrity of you
know their cases their information and
also the families that are there with us
um
you know we're learning as we go and we
we just we
we cannot ever afford to let that happen
um while we're at the level we're at and
where we're going
um you know we
we strive to be as professional as we
can because we know
agencies and departments are watching
what we're doing and the last thing we
ever want is to come to town to work a
case and you know department be like
heck no you guys are a clown show you
know instead it's the opposite
yeah yeah yeah i mean you guys happen to
just have a huge youtube following but
you're not doing it for attention and
that that's very clear
um yeah yeah so you're so you're sipping
on silverstar
from the uh
yes you know from texas which is south
of oklahoma for those that are listening
that are not familiar with some people
beneath
oklahoma well you know we
horns horns down that's what we do here
horns down i like oklahoma i like
oklahoma barbecue i like oklahoma's
they're they're they're a great barbecue
company
tulsa is a great city
yeah i'm guessing you've been here if
you're dropping oklahoma joe's and so
forth i mean you've legit been here
you're not just throwing stuff or you
did a little research on the internet so
one oh no no no no no i've i've been
there a few times and i actually uh
filmed a tick tock with oklahoma joe's
and their manager there on site
got a
back back room uh back house you know
tour and it was it was awesome
nah nice nice well what
what i was gonna get to the one that you
picked that bottle up down there in
texas i mean i think that's the longest
uh missing person case you guys have
been involved with if i'm correct yeah
someone who's missing about 30 years
that is the um
longest case that we have solved
actually solved which is 30 years and uh
it was carrie mae parker
yeah tell us about that one i mean she
was a young lady when she went missing
yeah yeah um again you know there's a
very young beautiful
young mom
who
was traveling home to her son's birthday
party
uh went to the store after work to pick
pick up a bicycle for her son never
showed up to the birthday party
and uh
um you know the the dynamics that play
out within a family
when somebody goes missing
pretty brutal pretty brutal yeah they
are they are
they they will they will tear families
apart
and
um
you're you're left you're forced to be
left with filling in the what-ifs and
you know as an officer you know a lot of
times
actions that
aren't suspicious end up looking really
suspicious you know um
people that i guess maybe you might
label weird or
just not normal which there's a lot of
them um end up man that that that
behaviors
that that behavior is suspicious he
definitely did something she definitely
did something
so it's uh
and that was similar dynamics that
played out in her entire family um over
three decades and
we were able to
uh
find her car right off of a little
causeway in lake tahwakeny
and it was just just an accident just an
accident you know the the causeway
barely had a railing and
um
yeah that was uh
it's always tough when we find these
people you know and
it's but it's answers it's answers for
families and an entire community and
departments
um it's closure and it is it is it it is
in a way we we we liked it in a way say
it's never closure because you'll never
get over losing someone that you love
you'll never get over that but knowing
knowing is yeah you know
yeah no matter how brutal the outcome
was knowing is everything knowing gives
because if you don't know and i try to
relate to these families and i never can
and working with so many of them and
solving so many cases i can never
imagine losing my daughter or my wife or
anyone close to me and never
knowing just one of them
falling off the face of the earth
i i yeah i can't even begin to relate
what that would feel like and you have
to put up you have to put up walls
mentally and emotionally to even move
forward in any way
so you know when we're able to provide
those answers it's just those walls just
they're gone you know well doug i'll say
this man you're saying you can't relate
to them but
i mean i'm telling you you know being a
cop howard being a nurse you know you
obviously have to see
my case victims families his case you
know uh you know people that are passing
away or you know very very sick in the
hospital have to deal with their
families
it goes a long way to these families of
these people that if you
you know are shown empathy and you show
your care but just having you on here
obviously you've left a profession that
you said you did since you're a teen
because you believe in this so much and
just talking to you about this and how
immediately every incident we're talking
about you're spitting the name about at
the name out the location the story
it shows how much it does mean to you so
i promise you
you're saying you can't relate to these
families they appreciate it without a
doubt he's pretty damn empathetic no
yeah i mean it does it it goes a long
way for sure and man what other you know
we only got five minutes or so left
when you guys are out on these deals um
and we'll just whether it be you know
the parker one we're talking about or
the lopez or whoever it is when you guys
get out there and start your search
or is anybody from the family even
present when these things happen or is
it just kind of it varies from case to
case
it does vary from case to case however
um
with us growing you know 20 plus million
views a month
we we usually always either have family
or law enforcement um that are there
with us assisting us on set while we're
searching hand-in-hand
all right i've got a question
you guys are centrally located in near
portland oregon right right in the
center of the u.s you're coming down to
russellville you're going to
pennsylvania
you you guys are putting and you i
assume southwest doesn't let you check
your sonar equipment and boat do they
no right i don't know
yeah i want to know i want to know what
kind of truck you drive because that
seems like a pretty dependable whip that
you have there and how many miles are
you how many miles are you putting on
that thing
on on every trip you know where we're
putting in you know three to four
thousand miles minimum um
you know we try to set our cases you
know
five to eight hours away from each other
with so many cases we just try to put a
bam bam bam bam bam that way we're
efficient with time mileage funds
et cetera you know we use an rv
uh we started out with a really old
janky rv it was gorilla taped up and
fortunately our supporters have allowed
us to uh upgrade from that but now we
have a newer rv and
we pull our equipment trailer
our supporters have stepped up big time
we now have two rvs
uh our two those two rvs are pulling two
27 foot dive units behind them
and it's all possible because of the
public you know and those two trailers
are now going to be two teams so now we
are focusing on you know we've been able
to solve 23 cases in the last two years
and with one team
on a shoestring budget and now we're
focusing on splitting up and having two
teams and we hope to
try to double those numbers in the next
two years
fantastic fantastic all right so real
quick doug we've got to hear all about
you what about jared man uh is he still
this kind of full-time gig for him or is
he you know
what's happening absolutely absolutely
you know jared's my best friend jared is
an amazing
father
husband
he cares about this just as much as i do
he's serious about it um he every he's
he's
on vacation right now he's done nothing
but work the entire time he's there and
i'm i'm texting him like dude like you
you gotta spend time for you you know
but he's always working no matter what
he's always working he has
i've built companies for a lot of people
but i've never been involved with
somebody who has taken everything almost
that they've made and invested it
right back into what we're doing and it
shows everything we've done
for the last three or four years it
shows you know now we have two plus
million on
youtube the equipment advancement in it
and you know all the stuff that he's
doing behind the scenes that nobody ever
sees you know so you know
hats off to him and great guy man i i
wish he was able to be here with us but
he had an outing with his family he
wasn't able to
um schedule it and it was planned a long
time ago but
um oh smart really really great with the
family
yeah all right man before we let you
bounce out of here where can people find
you on youtube instagram if you're on
twitter and so forth and how can they
donate
adventureswithpurpose.com is our website
you can make donate donations you can
find our merchandise on there as well uh
we have window breakers you know 50 of
our cases probably could have been
prevented if uh a window breaker would
have been accessible inside of the
vehicle uh also youtube you know we not
we know understand that not everybody
can donate or buy merchandise but
something as simple as subscribing to
youtube is free
is enough you know viewing our stuff
sharing our stories being there to
support us on any level
contributes to making what we do
possible
man it was a pleasure having you
absolutely you're doing the good work
out there sir so here thank you thank
you
appreciate it brother adventures with
purpose find them on youtube or on their
website yeah i like youtube
you guys have a wonderful evening
youtube brother